hey guys so we're at a Vanity Fair party
phosphors week was a lot of stuff going
on actually just got back to Australia
and haven't even posted any my
Australian law so stay tuned for that oh
look at you oh my goodness just really
good lighting so I just really like
looking at myself Wow ok you're like how
we gonna do that and it doesn't seem
like there
I haven't seen you office we did our
weight wind admitted it
video yahoo yeah there's a lot more
weird thing
like when i get back from an
international trip i'm in soft hands for
like three days I don't leave my house i
wake up at like 3am truthfully i would
say i would be doing right now like I
don't know how I got here you landed at
six-thirty and then I went back and take
a short little nap my alarm was going
off with two and a half hours I almost
missed it so we're good we're good I
just got a shower before I got into my
bed because I have international jerk
like an airplane Australia let's go this
little guy go let's go yeah but you were
let's go I want to go back oh my god is
over the Great Barrier Reef of love I
want to actually go do things in a
shortening and thats related they do
have that and they have the best coffee
down let's go now
a couple days for like 12 hours it was
amazing these would not believe the
coffee there is coffee shops if you
would walk like two feet and there'd be
another one individual like I'm not
going to cost you
coffee I'm not yet but I don't like it
you'll like this
well I'll drink all your coffee do you
like what you like coffee yeah i lost my
drink your coffee but I had one I'm very
lovely
oh hi just got back from the panel I've
just realized that it on my vlog I'm so
jet-lagged so I'm gonna go to bed sorry
this was so short I don't know Australia
vlog they will be up soon I've got some
cooking videos coming out for you guys
so stay tuned I'm gonna go to bed right
now